I was just waiting patiently because  obviously I'm listening to the guys  behind me there's a lot of things I  think you can see from my face that are  actually winding me up and I thought am  I going to take a break here or just be  polite and sit quietly because you  talked about  uh women I think the word used was  combat combative combative yeah they  were yeah it that was I was sitting here  and that was winding me up constantly  the way that you and others were talking  about older women or could be vice versa  and older men and I was just getting  more and more angry and I thought well  just sit quietly and see what you've all  got to say and we all have personal  opinions  but it doesn't mean that just because  you're with an older woman  that um they are taking advantage of you  and you're just having fun how about  consider that somebody a little bit  older than you might actually be  interested in you it's not always so fun